und dieser tag ist ein ganz
entscheidender tag für unsere gaspreise
in deutschland die knall ja längst durch
die decke und jetzt macht der kanzler
das zur chefsache endlich chefsache
gaspreis olaf scholz wird gleich bei
siemens zu besuch sein in mülheim bild
natürlich live dabei und dort bei
siemens da geht es ganz konkret um die
russischen gaslieferungen die hat putin
ja auch deshalb so gekürzt weil er sagt
mir fehlt eine ganz wichtige deutsche
turbine die ihr mir wegen der sanktionen
nicht rechtzeitig repariert habt jetzt
gleich wird der kanzler persönlich genau
diese so wichtige gasturbine besichtigen
und klarmachen nein putin die ist fertig
die isra pariert es gibt keine ausrede
mehr die gaslieferungen zu kürzen
deutschlands wichtigste turbine sie
wiegt 20 tonnen ist rund 14 meter lang
eine maschine wie ein monster und längst
ein politikum denn eigentlich soll sie
helfen russisches gas durch die 1200
kilometer lange ostseepipeline nord
stream eins zu pumpen doch seit wochen
liegt die turbine lahm wird gewartet
repariert weit weg in kanada und putin
sagt ohne diese turbine gibt es noch
weniger gas für euch deutsche
eine ausrede denn die turbine ist längst
wieder fit liegt fertig gewartet in
deutschland bereit den nord stream
dienst wieder aufzunehmen
doch russland hat die monster maschine
immer noch nicht zurückgenommen jetzt
macht die bundesregierung druck grund
natürlich unsere deutsche gaskrise der
kanzler selbst besucht nun siemens in
mülheim und die wichtigste deutsche
turbine die botschaft des kanzlers hier
ist die maschine putin es gibt keine
ausrede mehr die gaslieferungen weiter
zu kürzen wie groß der druck jetzt schon
ist in dieser gaskrise das zeigt ein
neuer preisschock einer der größten
gasanbieter deutschlands der zieht die
preise an aber richtig
mega gaspreiserhöhung in deutschland
rheinenergie macht den anfang und drückt
uns die neuen preise rein und zwar satte
133 prozent die leihe tranken die kölner
bevölkerung zum ersten oktober steigt
der gaspreis für mehr als zwei millionen
kunden um mehr als das doppelte an der
preis pro kilowattstunde gas klettert
von bislang 7 87 cent auf 18,3 cent das
ist ein anstieg um 10 43 cent pro
kilowattstunde für einen deutschen
durchschnittshaushalt mit einem
jahresverbrauch von 10.000
kilowattstunden bedeutet dass rund 1000
euro mehr eine steigerung um über 100
prozent
das gas ist teuer fast 450 prozent mehr
als letztes jahr geschuldet dem krieg
und der fehlenden russischen lieferungen
vor zwei wochen geht kanzler olaf scholz
noch bei einer vierköpfigen familie von
einer umlage von 200 bis 300 euro mehr
im jahr aus energieunternehmen dürfen
diese umlage auf die bevölkerung
abwälzen
aber da gibt es einen haken bei der
rheinenergie erhöhung ist noch nicht mal
diese gartenanlage mit eingerechnet die
kommt nämlich noch obendrauf der hammer
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
geht sogar von einer fünf prozent
erhöhung aus und die familien trifft es
hart im extremfall sind das sogar fast
1000 euro mehr ein ende ist erst mal
nicht in sicht
ja und an diesem so wichtigen tag für
den gaspreis in deutschland an diesem
tag an mit der kanzler dieses thema zur
chefsache macht meldet sich er hier
plötzlich groß zu wort gerd schröder der
altkanzler der alte putin freund warum
soll ich mich entschuldigen so fragt er
im stern sich selbst und alle anderen
und damit schwingt er sich auf zum
großen problemlöser tenor dort in diesem
interview mit ihm hätte man jetzt keine
gaskrise wäre doch ganz einfach sagte
auch die zweite nord-stream-pipeline
einfach in betrieb nehmen dann wäre
alles gut krieg egal und schröder sagt
auch moskau würde den krieg so gerne per
verhandlungen beilegen also mehr dazu
gleich alt kanzler schröder der sich
ganz groß zu wort meldet hier heute wie
gewohnt als treuer putin freut und egal
ob gas oder strom wir alle sollen und
wollen ja auch alle kräftig sparen
überall wo es nur geht und an anderer
stelle da wird noch kräftig energie
verschleudert bei den ganz großen bei
der bahn zb der riesige bahntower hier
in berlin am potsdamer platz licht an
auch wenn nachts dort niemand mehr
arbeitet darüber hat bild berichtet und
das hat gewirkt sagt die bahn wir machen
das licht nach feierabend jetzt
revolution aus dass zumindest das
behauptet der konzern ab jetzt ja wegen
der weltweiten energiepreise licht aus
nach feierabend stimmt das wir haben das
gezeigt heute nacht liegt wirklich aus
bei der bahn dass die bilder also vom
potsdamer platz ja da hat man den
schalter
tatsächlich erwischt bei der bahn paar
lampen brennen noch möglicherweise hat
der ein oder andere ja tatsächlich auch
noch gearbeitet
oder doch noch mal vergessen den
schalter zu drücken aber da hat sich
schon etwas geändert also statt festtags
beleuchtung tatsächlich nur noch in ein
paar büros ein bisschen licht vor allen
dingen oben in den vorstandsetagen
vielleicht tatsächlich doch noch
gearbeitet worden also ohne verspätung
diesmal nicht im wesentlichen aus geht
doch deutsche baden frank schneider und
sein chef reporter ist dabei beim
kanzler und auch bei deutschlands
wichtigster turbine muss man sagen beide
möchte man sehen und von beiden möchte
man eigentlich wissen was ist da los ist
eine turbine die lange unterwegs die in
kanada unterwegs war jetzt ist der
kanzler dort vor ort und wir waren
natürlich erst mal wissen wo ist das
ding wo ist diese so wichtige turbine
und die sich so viele jetzt streiten
ja diese turbine die steht hinter mir in
einer halle und der kanzler ist gerade
hier vorbeigefahren für gut fünf minuten
und ja schon extrem hohe
sicherheitsvorkehrungen des hin muss ich
auch so eine weste tragen weil es hier
erst mal sicherheits gelände ist auf dem
wir uns bewegen und eben auch der
kanzler hier ist und der werkschutz und
die polizei haben ja auch weiträumig
alles abgesperrt dann wir kein risiko
eingehen wir können das einmal zeigen
wer hinter mir ist das tor wo der
kanzler gerade rein gefahren ist und
dahinter sind eben diese ganzen hallen
und in einer dieser hallen steht die
turbinen und wir dürfen sie dann auch in
einer halben stunde sehen da wären wir
natürlich live noch einmal zurückkommen
aber wir haben gerade schon etwas sehr
spannendes erfahren denn das was der ja
der gasquet radweg teilweise ebenso
schön sagte erzählt ist eine klassische
fake news haben hier eben schon vorab
mit einem der verantwortlichen sprechen
können von siemens und er sagt die
turbine steht hier seit einer guten
woche seitdem ist aus kanada zurück und
die kanal der wollten sie eben nicht
direkt nach russland liefern sondern
über zwischenstationen deutschland und
wir haben alle aus papiere der deutschen
seite haben wir aber der russischen
seite die gazprom besorgen müssen die
haben wenig und die bekommen wir auch
nicht und deshalb übernimmt eben auch
kein spediteur diese turbine dies mit
1200 meter lang wiegt 18 tonnen drei
meter hoch ein riesiges teil und das
muss über den landweg wahrscheinlich
über finden dann mit einem
schwertransport dorthin gebracht werden
und die spediteure sagen das mache ich
nicht wenn ich nicht weiß ob ich an der
russischen grenze überhaupt weiterkomme
und genau dadurch wird blockiert das
heißt es liegt ganz klar in der
russischen seite es gibt überhaupt keine
probleme hier hier ist man bereit man
kann sie sofort liefern dann drei bis
vier tagen wer sie in russland und wäre
auch ein satz klar sie ist top in
ordnung sie ist ob gewartet aber die
russen ja liefern diese papiere eben
nicht und wir wissen alle wahrscheinlich
warum es ist hatten allein politischen
grund ja und jetzt will der kanzler olaf
scholz eben heute klar machen hier ist
sie die turbine es gibt für dich für
putin keine ausrede mehr die
gaslieferungen zu reduzieren also dass
das zeichen
das aus mülheim nach moskau gehen soll
von olaf scholz da ist ja ordentlich
druck im kessel immer mehr deutsche
sagen mensch uns treffen die sanktion
möglicherweise härter als putin
mittlerweile vor allen dingen mit blick
auf herbst auf winter schauen wir mal
wie die stimmung auf der straße
mittlerweile ist frank
das ist ein schwachsinn hoch ziehen die
sanktionen treffen uns und nicht
russland also wenn ich jemanden
sanktionieren möchte dann muss ich das
auch so machen dass derjenige den ich
versuche zusammen zu nähren dass auch
merkt und im moment merken wir doch nur
die sanktionen und russland lacht sich
tot sie verkaufen ihr gas was sie uns
vorher mit günstigen zu günstigen
konditionen verkauft hätten verkaufen
die jetzt woanders hin und wir verkaufen
zur not noch viel teurer oder wir kaufen
zur not noch viel teurer wieder also wie
schwachsinniger kann man es nicht machen
also ich sehe er dass wir uns mit den st
sie und ruinieren als dass wir russland
damit wesentlich schaden hier hat das
merken der ernannte er enormen
preissteigerungen im bereich der energie
das merken wir an einer anderen
preissteigerungen im bereich der
lebensmittel es geht ja die inflation
rasant in die jugendlichen geht das erst
der anfang weil der krieg von der nato
mission ist genauso zu verantworten ist
sie von russland
dass also frank schneider unser
chefreporter die sorgen vieler menschen
die sanktionen die treffen uns
vielleicht am ende härter als die
russlands treffen wird dieser besuch
jetzt heute des kanzlers bei dieser so
wichtigen turbine denn irgendetwas
ändern ist heute der tag an dem wir ein
bisschen vielleicht die nachricht
bekommen am gaspreis wird sich was
ändern kann oder scholz da heute etwas
tun
ich glaube ganz einfach es ist ein ganz
klares politisches signal was kanzler
scholz aussenden würde insbesondere
natürlich an die bürger weil die werden
jetzt alle wirklich bluten müssen wenn
es darum geht dass die gaspreise
anbetrifft und da kommt auf die menschen
dazu am jahresende ich glaube das malen
wir uns jetzt alle noch nicht aus und er
will klar zeigen es liegt nicht an uns
ist liegt an russland er will sich
sozusagen selber aus der schusslinie
nehmen das ist momentan gefühlt das
einzige was er will er will noch mal
öffentlichen druck natürlich auch
erzeugen auf russland aber das wissen
wir auch wenn der kanzler hier durch die
turbine anguckt das wird putin nicht
beeindrucken ich glaube es ist ein
klares signal nur innerhalb deutschlands
dass man sagen will an uns liegt es
nicht wir sind nicht schuld gerade nach
dem jetzt gerhard schröder wir so ein
quatsch erzählen man muss ja sagen er
verbreitet einfach namen putins fake
news es ist eben einfach blödsinn dass
sie an siemens liegt die tu mine liegt
hier seit über sieben tagen sie ist
fertig ist top in ordnung sie kann
sofort nach russland mit einem
schwertransport aber die papiere der
russen seite sind nicht da und deshalb
geht auch nicht ob olaf scholz das heute
in irgendeiner form ändern kann wage ich
persönlich zu bezweifeln man kann nur
hoffen dass der öffentliche druck
vielleicht doch noch mal etwas erzeugt
aber ob es wirklich so ist das
entscheidet putin ganz allein peking ist
in dieser tag ist ein ganz
entscheidender tag für unsere gaspreise
in deutschland die knallen längst nicht
die decke und sie sehen hier kanzler
olaf scholz ist gerade bei siemens in
mülheim und im hintergrund ist sie wohl
im moment bedeutendste turbine jetzt
derzeit im gasstreit mit russland ja
denn die nimmt putin ja auch als vorwand
um zu sagen mensch ohne diese termine
geht im moment gar nichts da muss ich
euch das gas noch weiter reduzieren die
war zur reparatur zur wartung in kanada
und es hieß immer mensch ja moskau will
die zurück aber die kommt einfach nicht
nee nee sagt der kanzler heute hier
liegt die es fertig das fertige watt
fertig repariert ihr könnt die sofort
haben mir müsste im grunde nur nach
russland bringen also ganz wichtiger
besuch heute auch für ihren gaspreis zu
hause wir hören einmal rein da spricht
gerade der siemens energy chef dort
christian bruch also der hat sich mit
dem kanzler dort getroffen und es gibt
jetzt im kern um diese turbine den der
die beiden da stehen wir kurz wir haben
nicht transportieren können das wollen
wir jetzt natürlich lösen weil wir
natürlich hauptsächlich einfach an der
technik selber interessiert sind und
weniger an den politischen diskussionen
aber das ist das was wir halt im moment
sehen aber insofern ist das sind so dass
die hand und rahmenbedingungen
ich sage mal der installation in
botswana und deswegen
tun wir alles um schnellstmöglich eine
auslieferung hinzubekommen und wie
gesagt technisch können wir es aus
unserer sicht nicht nachvollziehen wo
man diese ein turbine jetzt die jetzige
lieferte trotz der bundeskanzler noch
mal ganz herzlich willkommen hier in
mühlheim vielen dank für ihre zeit
schönen dank schön dank für die
einladung schönen dank dass sich dieses
beeindruckende
stück technik hier bewundern kann das ja
auch zeit zu welcher ingenieursleistung
siemens fähig ist und auch ein gutes
beispiel dafür ist dass die
leistungsfähigkeit unserer industrie in
deutschland hier betrifft was mir
wichtig es ist klar zu machen dass diese
turbine jederzeit einsetzbar ist und
dass sie genutzt werden kann es steht
nichts ihren weitertransport nach
russland entgegen außer dass die
russischen
abnehmer mitteilen müssen dass sie die
termine auch haben wollen und die
notwendigen auskünfte für den zoll
transport nach russland geben alle
anderen genehmigungen liegen vor das
gilt für die genehmigung aus deutschland
das gilt für die genehmigung aus der
europäischen union aus dem vereinigten
königreich aus dem aus kanada es gibt
keine probleme und das ist auch nicht
weiter verwunderlich denn nicht nur die
turbine ist völlig um perfekt vorhanden
und kann jederzeit ein gebaut und
eingesetzt werden sondern es gibt ja
auch keinerlei gas sanktionen die der
turbinen nutzung entgegenstehen
sie erinnern sich dass wir als wir
angefangen haben richtigerweise als
reaktion auf den russischen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
sanktionen als europäische union als g7
staaten als gemeinschaft vieler länder
in der welt zu verhängen gast sanktionen
davon ausgeschlossen haben es gibt also
keine gründe warum diese lieferung nicht
stattfinden kann und das zu
demonstrieren zu verstehen und zu zeigen
ist ein grund warum ich sehr dankbar bin
dass ich das heute mit eigenen augen
ansehen konnte und auch für alle anderen
dazu beitragen kann dass hier nichts
mystisches zu betrachten ist es ist
gewissermaßen klar und einfach die
turbine ist da sie kann geliefert werden
es muss nur jemand sagen ich möchte sie
haben dann ist sie ganz schnell da und
das steht dann dem weiteren transport
des gases durch die pipeline nicht mehr
entgegen vielleicht sollte man auch dazu
sagen wir haben erhebliche pipeline
kapazitäten die verfügbar sind das ist
north stream 1 das ist die pipeline die
aus der ukraine kommt das ist auch
jedenfalls im prinzip die jamal-pipeline
durch belarus und polen die russland
selbst sanktioniert hat aber auch die
ist ja da und funktioniert die
lieferverpflichtungen die gazprom hat
gegenüber seinen europäischen abnehmern
können jederzeit erfüllt werden und zwar
uneingeschränkt alle vorgebrachten
technischen gründe sind nicht auf einer
faktenbasis nachvollziehbar und das
glaube ich gehört auch zur wahrheit dazu
für uns heißt das aber dass wir
verstehen müssen sehr genau dass es
nicht ausreicht alles richtig zu machen
sondern dass man in dieser schwierigen
situation die mit dem russischen
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine verbunden
ist immer klar sein muss dass es
jederzeit irgendwelche vorgeschobenen
vorgebrachten gründe geben kann die dazu
führen dass irgendetwas nicht
funktioniert
technische gründe haben ja dem gasexport
auch in andere länder europas schon
angeblich entgegen gestanden auch dort
waren sie genau so wenig nachvollziehbar
für uns aber bedeutet das dass wir uns
darauf einstellen müssen dass selbst
wenn das jetzt mit dem transport
funktioniert wenn die der gastransport
durch die aus dem einst pipeline wieder
gut funktioniert es unverändert so sein
wird dass jederzeit es neu los gehen
kann und darauf haben wir uns
vorbereitet sehr früh und sehr früh die
notwendigen entscheidungen getroffen im
dezember des letzten jahres habe ich
bereits das wirtschaftsministerium und
die verantwortlichen bei mir im
kanzleramt darum gebeten sich mit der
frage zu beschäftigen was passiert
eigentlich wenn wir kein gas mehr
bekommen und als dann der krieg
im februar begann waren wir in der lage
alle notwendigen entscheidungen schnell
auf den weg zu bringen die eine
komplette kehrtwende gegenüber den
bisherigen umgangsweisen mit der
gasversorgung aus russland bedeutet
haben die erste entscheidung war wir
machen uns unabhängig so dass wir
jedenfalls was die infrastrukturen
betrifft jederzeit in der lage sind gas
auch anderswo zu bestellen und zu
importieren nicht nur über die west
europäischen häfen mit den niederlanden
in belgien und frankreich oder auch aus
großbritannien sondern eben auch über
eigene flüssiggas terminals an den
norddeutschen küsten wir haben
sondergesetze beschlossen die uns jetzt
in die lage versetzen werden dass die
ersten terminals wahrscheinlich zum
beginn des nächsten jahres anfangen zu
laufen einige etwas später so dass wir
relativ schnell
importkapazitäten was die infrastruktur
betrifft haben werden die uns in die
lage versetzen jederzeit wenn auch
möglicherweise zu hohen preisen gast von
anderswo zu bestellen und auch zu
importieren das geschieht gerade mit
großem tempo die zweite entscheidung die
wir getroffen haben war dass wir dafür
sorge tragen dass die speicher in
deutschland gefüllt sind ein thema das
mich sehr umgetrieben hat und dass wir
gelöst haben mit einem gesetz dass wir
auf den weg gebracht haben dass
speicherverpflichtung vorgesehen hat
denn das war doch bemerkenswert dass
teilweise sogar aus diesen speichern in
andere länder geliefert wurde zum
beispiel nach polen statt die
möglichkeiten der nach polen führende
gaspipeline zu nutzen das musste man
richtig verstehen und wir haben es
richtig verstanden in dem wir die
entscheidung getroffen haben es gibt
gesetze und verordnungen die
vorschreiben dass die speicher gefüllt
werden müssen und wo die betreiber der
speicher es nicht machen wir das dann
mit unseren eigenen möglichkeiten über
die dazu verantwortlichen tun das
geschieht gegenwärtig sie wissen wir
haben die anforderungen noch einmal
verschärft so dass wir jetzt eine 1 5
stand bei den speichern haben wir in den
letzten jahren zu diesem zeitpunkt nicht
existiert hat und wir ohne dieses gesetz
nicht wäre die dritte entscheidung die
wir getroffen haben ist dass wir gesagt
haben wir wollen gas sparen insbesondere
bei der stromproduktion und wir werden
deshalb kohlekraftwerke wieder in
betrieb nehmen die schon vom netz
gegangen waren das erste das haben sie
gerade gemeldet ist jetzt wie der markt
bereit und liefert strom für das netz
und wir werden weitere sehen die das
auch tun das alles dient der
vorbereitung auf eine schwierige zeit
und die vierte maßnahme die wir zur
vorbereitung auf schwierige zeiten
treffen ist dass wir dafür sorge tragen
dass wir alle da wo es geht das sparen
ich kriege aus vielen unternehmen in
deutschland jetzt jeden tag rückmeldung
wie entscheidungen getroffen werden zum
zur reduktion des eigenen gasverbrauchs
darunter sind auch entscheidungen die
wahrscheinlich auch nach dieser
gegenwärtigen schwierigen situation
bestand haben werden weil das ja in
vielen fällen auch einfach geld spart
wenn man etwas klüger und anders umgeht
jedenfalls ist es so dass viele solche
entscheidungen überall getroffen werden
ich merke auch von vielen bürgern und
bürgern dass sie sich selbst bereits
vorbereiten wir haben mit einigen
maßnahmen die wir angekündigt und
vorbereitet haben auch unseren beitrag
dazu geleistet dass wir so viel
sicherheit schaffen in dem wir auch
selber alle miteinander sparen was
möglich ist ohne dass es zu erheblichen
beeinträchtigung unserer lebensqualität
und nur der wirtschaftsentwicklung kommt
und die viert fünfte maßnahme die dazu
gehört ist dass wir sehr früh
entschieden haben dass es auch
entlastungen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger geben muss zwei pakete von
insgesamt 30 milliarden sind bereits auf
den weg gebracht viele der maßnahmen
wirken bereits einige kommen jetzt und
zwar gerade jetzt wo die preise steigen
dazu zählt zum beispiel dass wir über 20
milliarden euro belastung vom strompreis
runter genommen haben in dem sat mitte
diesen jahres die eeg umlage nicht mehr
erhoben wird mit der folge dass der
strompreis entsprechend entlastet ist
dazu zählten die populäre diskutierten
maßnahmen mit dem neuen euro ticket und
dem rabatt an den tankstellen den wir
möglich gemacht haben dazu zählt dass
wir wirtschaftliche entlastung auf den
weg gebracht haben indem wir die im
arbeitnehmer pauschbetrag angehoben
haben den grundfreibetrag angehoben
haben für alle arbeitnehmern und
arbeitnehmer wir haben dazu beigetragen
dass es zahlungen gibt an familien mit
wenig geld 20 euro mehr jeden monat seit
juli das gleiche gilt für eine
einmalzahlung für alle kinder von 100
euro bezahlen an die
grundsicherungsempfänger 200 euro und im
nächsten monat werden alle bürgerinnen
bürger die
bei ihrem arbeitseinkommen nachschauen
auf der lohnabrechnung sehen dass es
eine entscheidung gegeben hat mit einer
energiepreis pauschale dazu beizutragen
dass es eine steuerliche entlastung gibt
die wirksam wird also quasi zur
richtigen zeit wenn man diese maßnahmen
mit im blick hat alles das soll helfen
dass wir durch die schwierige situation
kommen und wir werden weitere maßnahmen
ergreifen gerade da wo es knapp es im
geldbeutel weil viele bürgerinnen und
bürger hier keine rücklagen haben
aufbauen können deshalb unsere
entscheidung dass wir das wohngeld
substanziell ausbauen und verbessern und
dass wir auch die reform der
grundsicherung zum ersten januar 23 auf
den weg bringen zwei maßnahmen die
helfen sollen durch diese schwierige
situation und wir auf alle fälle wichtig
finden damit alle eine möglichkeit haben
die schwierige zeit zu durchstehen das
ist jetzt ein moment wo wir als land
zusammenstehen müssen aber es ist auch
ein moment in dem wir zeigen können wozu
wir in der lage sind und dass wir so
früh und so rechtzeitig beginnt mit dem
dezember des letzten jahres mit den
vorbereitungen anfang des jahres und mit
den entscheidungen seit dem
kriegsausbruch
vorgegangen sind früh gehandelt haben
das hilft uns jetzt in dieser
schwierigen situation
hier an einem ort wo wir eine wirklich
große technologische leistung bewundern
dürfen können wir nur sagen unseren
beitrag werden wir gerne dazu leisten
dass die energielieferung die gas
lieferung nach europa ungehindert
stattfinden können es gibt keine
technischen gründe die dagegen stehen
das kann man hier vor ort ganz genau
besichtigen diese turbine funktioniert
hagen
hier steht das ding gut den kannst du
haben die große nord stream 1 turbine
die kann sofort nach moskau zurück
kommen und jetzt gibt es noch fragen an
olaf scholz an den bundeskanzler dort in
mülheim heute bei diesem so wichtigen
termin bei dem auch für ihren gaspreis
so wichtigen termin die frage können wir
gerade nicht hören dort in der
werkshalle bei siemens energy in mülheim
aber wir hören auf die antwort
gas aus russland importiert mit sehr
vielen sehr unterschiedlichen
regierungen auch in den letzten 16
jahren der regierung von frau merkel an
dem die spd in der tat auch häufiger
beteiligt war in diesen letzten 16
jahren hat sich an dieser import
struktur nichts geändert ich selber habe
mich sehr früh übrigens auch von manchen
dafür sehr heftig kritisiert dafür
eingesetzt dass wir unsere
infrastrukturen ausbauen und dafür sorge
tragen dass das flüssiggas terminals an
den norddeutschen küsten gibt das habe
ich schon gemacht als ich noch
bürgermeister in hamburg war das habe
ich als finanzminister und vizekanzler
fortgesetzt so mancher empörung gut wäre
gewesen wir wären damals mit dem bau
dieser flüssiggasterminals bereits
gestartet dann werden sie jetzt bereits
fertigen wie könnten sie unter ohne
sondergesetze in betrieb nehmen die
informationen sind aber sehr eindeutig
es gibt keine technischen gründe für den
die reduktion der gaslieferungen durch
nord stream 1 es gibt funktionierende
turbinen hier steht eine der austausch
dieser turbinen kann im klassischen
routine rhythmus weiter stattfinden wie
das in den letzten jahren auch immer der
fall war es müsste nur gazprom als
derjenige der das zu bekommen hat sagen
ich möchte die turbine auch haben und da
es keine rechtlichen gründe gibt die dem
export aus deutschland aus europa
entgegen stehen wäre es schön es gebe
auch keine rechtlichen einwände mehr die
dem import nach russland entgegen stehen
wir können ja schlecht sagen wir fahren
das jetzt irgendwo an den in den hafen
von
sankt petersburg zum beispiel und laden
das da auf der kaikante ab und sagen da
ist das teil sondern es wäre schon gut
wenn das geordneter weise funktioniert
im gesagt an der stelle hätten wir es
gerne da soll es auf den lastwagen und
dann geht es an den bestimmungsort es
gibt keine gründe die dagegen sprechen
bitte hier ist die nächste frage
ulrich klose rtl n tv
man hat ja nicht nur ein eindruck das
ist ein stück technik ist diese turbine
sondern inzwischen ein großes politikum
habe hat er schon mehrfach gesagt er
glaube dass die russen die gar nicht
zurück haben wollen ist das auch ihr
eindruck und zweitens machen sie nun die
turbine zur chefsache
das ist eine sache von ingenieuren und
ingenieurinnen vielen arbeiterinnen und
arbeitern die dafür sorgen dass diese
turbine gebaut wurde und dass sie stets
gewartet und gepflegt wird und die alle
sagen das ding ist perfekt sein einbau
kann sofort durch vockel durchgeführt
werden und um diese debatte zu
entmystifizieren habe ich mir gedacht
wer ist vielleicht ganz sinnvoll wenn
wir uns die mal gemeinsam anschauen ich
und sie mit mir gemeinsam damit man
sieht es gibt sie wirklich sie steht
hier sie ist einsatzbereit und es ist
übrigens in der welt in der wir heute
leben etwas ganz einfaches sie zu
transportieren es muss nur einer sagen
bitte schickt sie los
die zurückhaben wollen
spekulationen in dieser sache machen
keinen sinn
klarheit
festigkeit ist erforderlich nämlich dass
wir uns nicht von diesen spekulationen
abhängig machen deshalb habe ich ja
schon sehr früh entschieden dass wir
alle notwendigen entscheidungen treffen
um mit jeder entwicklung der situation
umgehen zu können denn das wäre ja ganz
falsch wenn wir einfach nur hoffen dass
andere sich an die verträge halten an
die vereinbarung die sie lange
geschlossen haben sondern wir müssen ja
davon ausgehen dass das nicht mehr so
sicher ist russland hat über jahrzehnte
aus den zeiten des kalten krieges
noch die botschaft übersandt egal was
los ist es wird immer geliefert und
deshalb spricht so wenig dafür jetzt die
turbine nicht empfang zu nehmen und die
gaslieferung durch nord stream 1 unter
die anderen pipelines die aktiv im
betrieb sein könnten durch polen zb oder
durch die ukraine die besser genutzt
werden könnten nicht durchzuführen und
das ist glaube ich für russlands zukunft
auch eine schwierige botschaft wenn in
der welt 2 für entstehen dass man sich
an vereinbarungen die das land getroffen
hat abgeschlossen hat noch sicher auf
die sicher verlassen kann
hier vorne ist die nächste folgen putin
hat angeboten die pipeline nord sind
zwei doch zu nutzen und bürgermeister
aus ostdeutschland schlagen das auch
schon vor ist das für sie vorstellbar
dass nord stream 2 benutzt wird um über
diesen oder die nächsten winter zu
kommen wir haben den genehmigungsprozess
beendet aus guten gründen und ich glaube
wir sollten auch immer mal wieder ein
bisschen
uns besinnen und die wirklichkeit
betrachten es gibt genügend kapazitäten
bei nordstream 1 da ist überhaupt kein
mangel an
möglichkeiten alle verträge die russland
geschlossen hat für ganz europa mit
hilfe dieser pipeline und der auch noch
in betrieb befindlichen ukraine pipeline
zu erfüllen und wir dürfen nicht
vergessen es gibt ja sogar eine
pipeline die esw existiert und seit
jahrzehnten in betrieb war die ging
durch geht durch belarus und polen
russland selbst hat entschieden diese
pipeline zu sanktionieren whatever
das des - und deshalb sage ich
ausdrücklich das hat alles keinen
vernünftigen sinn trotzdem müssen wir
uns mit dieser situation
auseinandersetzen deshalb also ein
beitrag zur offenheit klarheit und
transparenz die maschine ist
gewissermaßen nicht zum anfassen aber
zum anschauen für alle hier da und jeder
kann so genau auf sie halten mit seiner
kamera wie er möchte um zu verstehen die
ist wirklich vorhanden und funktioniert
und das zweite ist dass wir klar uns
immer klar machen egal was los ist wir
müssen damit rechnen dass verträge
möglicherweise nicht beachtet werden und
darauf haben wir uns sehr sehr
sorgfältig vorbereitet und werden das
auch weiter tun
und welche freunde die nächste frage
ja so weiter also der kanzler olaf
scholz der sagt hier stütze die turbine
für nord stream 1 die es fertig die ist
nicht kaputt die es fertig gewartet
repariert moskau kann sie sofort haben
die steht den russischen gaslieferungen
nach deutschland nicht mehr im weg herr
putin das also eine wichtige geschichte
dieses tages der kanzler der das gas zur
chefsache machen
[Musik]